[Music]  did you know you can reduce food waste  with a nap when restaurants and cafes  call it a day they often have leftover  food which they throw away that's how  every year over 1 million tons of  edibles end up in the garbage in Germany  alone  the startup too good to go wanted to do  something about that they developed an  app designed to reduce food waste with  the app customers can order food that  otherwise would be thrown away later  when the restaurant closes they can pick  up their order they just show the  receipt and take home perfectly edible  food for less than four euros the  business earns a little extra and cuts  down waste disposal costs it's a win-win  situation for everyone involved since  the company was set up in 2015 over 1  million meals have been saved  [Music]  do you like that if you are also doing  your bit tell us about it  visit our website or send us a tweet  hashtag doing your bed we share your  stories  [Music]